Firstly...
an angel appears
to prophesy.
The angel says the name
of the recipient first.
They are then told
when they will die,
and that they are bound
for Hell.
When the time comes,
the executors of Hell...
are going to fulfill
the prophesy.
If you're watching this
for the first time,
you may find this shocking.
He looks completely normal.
But why is he bullshitting
everyone?
I couldn't
believe it either.
Wait, people actually
believe this crap?
Yeah, There are a lot
of people who believe it.
He has a bunch of videos
that back him
on his YouTube channel.
Okay, yeah.
Con men like him
can exploit people
because of idiots like you.
Don't take this seriously,
all right?
Wait, you are taking this
seriously, aren't you?
So?
Watch it again and see
if you still feel the same.
-This is all CGI!
-No, it's not.
-What's going on?
-What is happening?